nick of course winning a super bowl mvp
and he joins us now after the win last
night
uh nick do you want to weigh in on the
poll question uh would you take your
career
or robert orry's career he won seven nba
titles
yeah i mean that's a pretty amazing
career it'd be hard to go
um to not choose seven nba towers but
you know i've been
i've been very blessed throughout my
career so since it's me i'll just you
know i'm grateful for the career i've
had
last time i saw you i was on the podium
and you were holding your daughter
after winning the super bowl mvp and
i was how old is she now she she's three
three she's three and she she actually
just went in our basement she's
out there playing around with with my
wife and our dog and our son sleeping
right now so
just enjoying some family time i'm
guessing your daughter doesn't remember
anything
about that night when the eagles won the
title i
i don't think so i don't think she does
but when she sees pictures of it she
says there's baby lily
so she she does remember she doesn't
know what she was like as a baby but she
has no clue
yeah and when you think about when you
reflect back on that like what
is there one thing that stands out about
that night when you won the super bowl
yeah i think it's just uh you don't know
what it's going to be like i mean
obviously it's a childhood dream to do
that
and until you've done it you don't know
and i think that you know the moment
when it's over the moment you're
celebrating
obviously you're there when i was
holding lily and just embracing my
family but
you really realize like you you step
back and you you look at the people you
you went through this journey with and
you see them embracing their family and
loved ones
and uh complete joy um because it's not
an easy road to get to you know be
super bowl champions and in that moment
you really realize
you know the joy and the journey that
this game provides
and it's a much more than a trophy it's
the journey and the
people you go through it with but you
got a statue as well nick
right yeah yeah it's uh it's wild to
think there's a statue
in front of the link from uh from a
moment that was simply just uh to score
against
the patriots and it was a play that we
felt like would work in that time and
had no idea what what that play would be
like what did you say
from that super bowl what did i say
save oh save uh
let's see i mean a lot of this stuff is
in the hall of fame
um obviously we
we found in a box because we've
obviously moved a few times but we found
in a box my philly special glove
which was uh pretty cool i had wondered
where it went and then i realized oh
there it is because it was in a
in my super bowl stuff so i'd imagine
that that's a pretty valuable piece of
memorabilia
um but i think it'll be great in our
son's room at some point we don't
have anything around the house or
anything if my kids ever want to take
some of my jerseys or my stuff we'll
take them out of boxes
and let them do that um but uh
i'm surprised that glove is not in the
hall of fame nick
yeah uh i am too i am too well
they're probably gonna call you they're
probably gonna go oh i know they're
probably listening to this show and i'm
gonna call right after this and
everything but you know someday i have
to take my kids there so they can see it
uh did you ever find tom brady you were
looking for him after the game
the camera was on you did you realize
that uh i didn't realize that the camera
was on
me um obviously uh everyone's trying to
you know keep their distance and do that
thing
um i was looking for him real quick but
you know once again we'll
we'll find a time down the road it was
it was a hard fought battle on both
sides
it was a fist fight so um you know
that's a
that was a tough game i'm glad we came
out on top how would you describe that
game if
if somebody didn't see that game and you
were trying to sum it up for them how
would you sum it up
oh it's just a just a fist fight like it
was uh
you know throw stats out the window it's
just
you know keep fighting keep fighting
keep fighting and uh
don't give up because it wasn't the
prettiest game by any means
um but we you know the team that just
continued to fight and
tama bay is a great team i mean they've
had a great start to the season
they're well coached they have talented
players on both sides of the ball
um but it wasn't pretty but it was one
of those games you're really grateful
that you come out with a victory
but did you think you left too much time
on the clock with that
that you know final drive there where
you know it's brady and you're like oh
my gosh
you know you look up and you go you're
doing the math there with uh the time
left
you know what uh been in that situation
before with tom
and there was time but that's where it's
you know our defense
came up huge so many times last night we
really have a great locker room
and that show that showed through this
first part of the season
um the games we have not made the games
easy on ourselves but ultimately
the character of the locker rooms
prevailed and uh you know we had
complete trust in our defense at the end
they had caused havoc all game and it
didn't make it easy on
tom and their offense so i was really
really proud of our defense to get that
huge stop
then i uh i applauded you on the air not
it
not that it made its way back to you but
how you've handled the mitchell trubisky
and that's tricky
but you've been in these situations
before and you know you're just saying
look i don't know if i'm the starter
next week and then you know because
mitchell trubisky was a high draft pick
and you're brought in
you're not sure if you're going to be
able to compete for the job and
like how how do you approach something
like that where in your heart you're a
competitor and you think you're
the better quarterback but you also have
to be professional
about your approach to that
yeah and you know what first and
foremost you know mitch is an extremely
talented quarterback i've been able to
be around him here you know
since i got here and working with him
and seeing what he can do
from a from an athletic standpoint from
moving around throwing the ball making
plays i've really enjoyed being around
him
um but first and foremost it's really
just developing a relationship
apart from football so when we're in the
film room or when just getting to know
each other as people first and foremost
because sometimes like you said football
becomes tricky especially in the qb room
and it can get extremely weird and this
this hasn't been a difficult
i mean this has not been an easy
situation you know for the first part of
season for either of us
but i feel like that foundation we set
in training camp where we genuinely got
to know each other
has really helped through these times
and once again not easy for either
of us throughout this but i feel like
you know mitch has been amazing
throughout this process
and it's been a healthy qb room if
somebody's watching on tv it almost
looks like you're the lion king
because of the mirror behind you you
know what i saw this i was asking
and you know obviously we've been moving
in and we just got a little office and
i i opened up the zoom and i'm like man
that i got to figure this out so people
know it's a mirror
it's my first time sitting in the office
so oh
i i'm just telling you this is what's
going to happen nick people are going to
go who does nick foles think he is he's
dressing up like
you know it is halloween season but it
looks like you're the lion king with uh
the no matches my hat
i guess it works you know it'll give
someone something to instagram or do
something well wait
what was plan b if it wasn't gonna work
you have two
two uh uh lights lamps on the side and
then you've got a huge mirror
and it looks like the mirror is made out
of bamboo or something but it looks like
you have a headdress on yeah i mean plan
b
was honestly going in the basement but i
felt like you deserved more than that
thank you
this actually was for you i was like i
gotta figure this out i hope my computer
is charged
like you know so i did this lion king
setup was for you
did you watch the game when you got home
do you want no no i i got home and i
just sat there with my wife
and we i was starving so i ate a lot of
food i went to sleep
oh okay so then but you watch the game
footage today
i watch it today so we just went in and
we we get tested like every day
picked up my family some breakfast i'll
do some recovery and get the filming
today
but uh it was a late night didn't get
home till probably like one or something
so
just giving myself a little time to rest
he plays for the bears but he's the lion
king he's uh nick foles hey it's great
to talk to you thanks for joining us we
appreciate you
uh making all of that effort to give us
this special room as opposed to
a basement absolutely dan anything for
you man thank you i appreciate that wise
man nick foles
the lion king